you know one of the things I remember
more than anything else is just looking
up and realizing how stupid I was with
money I mean you ever done something and
you just want to like how you look in
the mirror you go you're just dumb I
mean it's just it's like I've done so
many dumb things in my life and I just
go oh if I survived all this stupidity
and you know it's just God's grace I
guess and you just get another chance
and next day you're not as dumb as you
were the day before I mean I've done it
I mean the stuff I have done and that I
look back on I think I've made every
financial mistake I never did a payday
loan I didn't do that one and I the only
reason I didn't lease a car was they
turned me down because I was so broke
but I that song I would at least one I
tried to Lisa you don't remember a brand
I don't know if there's a make these
cars anymore Apuzzo I tried to lease a
push oh now that's too dumb things
number one it was a push Oh number two I
was trying to lease it I mean I've done
so many stupid things and still managed
to do enough smart things because I
learned from my stupid that we built
wealth what we all done stupid stuff and
the thing is you can wander into debt
but you can't wander out and the only
way you win with money or win at
anything for that matter is you do it on
purpose you've become very intentional
and make every dollar behave with your
budget right you need a plan but it's
kind of like are y'all any of you old
enough that you're a parent maybe it was
a regional thing I think maybe was an
age thing we used to go when I was a
little kid they would just throw us in
the car and we would go on Sunday
afternoon drives and just drive to
nowhere around and look at stuff I mean
with no destination now the only time I
do that now is if I get out like one of
our classic
you know I've got a 1960 Corvette and if
it's a pretty Sunday Sharon and I might
drive around and do nothing just to be
in the car and just to be enjoying the
thing and have you know two old people
in an old car tooling around it's kind
of cool you know it's fun but the number
of times I get in the car now that I'm
not going somewhere it's almost zero
most the time I'm going somewhere and
I'm even learning how to work this
little smartphone thing I've got and
it'll tell you how to get there there's
a woman that lives inside that thing
that's bossy and she'll tell you where
to turn then that you missed your turn
and there's a blue line on the page and
the whole thing you know I mean you got
a destination and there's a step-by-step
plan to get to the destination and if
you want to go to Florida you've made
the wrong turn son you need to go that
way if you want to go to Michigan you
made the wrong turn you need to go that
way if you want to go to that restaurant
you made the wrong turn you know you you
don't get places on accident do you you
don't just go wandering around and go
look at that we ended up where we didn't
even know we were going if you aim at
nothing you'll hit it every time and
people spend more time selecting what
Netflix they're going to binge on then
laying out their monthly budget they
spend more time picking out a suit of
clothes than they do their career they
spend more time on stupid stuff than
they do on smart stuff haven't we all
done that and you know the difference in
people who are what we call successful
they're successful in their marriage
they're successful with their kids
they're successful in their business
they're successful in their spiritual
walk they're successful in their wealth
building it's because they do it on
purpose
they have a plan and they become their
own little bossy woman inside the
smartphone that tells themselves what to
do I have a plan and no I'm not going to
do that because it's not part of my plan
I'm not gonna impulse a new car or lease
because my plan is to build wealth and
I'm not gonna do that
that's dumb I'm not going to spend this
money because I didn't plan to spend
this money I'm not even going to be a
guilt-tripped into giving this money
because I hadn't planned to give this
money now if God tells me to do it I'll
do it but just because you told me to do
it doesn't mean I'm gonna do it and so
matter of fact good chance I'm not gonna
do it just because you said to I'm just
kind of obstinate that way so financial
peace universities are nine lesson class
we've taught this to 6 million people
here's what you do if you want to win
now you can go on a Sunday afternoon
drive with your money and most people do
they have no destination and they arrive
promptly at no destination if that's
your destination no you're gonna get
there you're going to get to no
destination every time and these are
people that wander along going I sure
hope the government which is well known
for its ability to handle money will
take care of me when I'm old well this
is a dumb but retirement plan does the
government can't add I mean there's a
bunch of new ones up there that can't
add they're everywhere basic math skills
are going out the window and so you
really have to take care of yourself and
the only way you're going to do that is
with a and in a series of intentional
acts and we'll show you how to get out
of debt and how to save for emergencies
and how start investing and how to
follow the path that 10,000 millionaires
that we studied have followed and so
that you can be able to put yourself in
a position to change your family tree
live your life generously it's your turn
but you're not gonna get anywhere if you
don't know where you're going it's an
intentional act and sometimes you need
somebody to show you how the map works
you know I'm the lime the mean little
woman inside the cell phone for money
that's it that's it it's my voice that's
inside the cell phone for when it comes
to money I'm the one that says don't buy
that that's stupid I'm the one that says
credit cards are stupid I'm the one that
says stay out of the payday lender I'm
the one that says to avoid
life life insurance I'm the one that
says leasing a car is stupid I'm the one
that says the credit card is the
cigarette of Finance it'll kill you
and it's not even popular anymore so
check out Financial Peace University go
to Dave Ramsey comm call customer call
our Ramsey concierto get you signed up
triple a 22-piece triple eight two two
seven three two two three guys you can
do that or not do it it's up to you but
the thing is this if winning is an
intentional act as a matter of fact it's
a series of intentional acts turn here
turn there don't turn here
OOP you missed your turn and you know of
course correct get there but you have a
freakin destination and you can tell if
you're making progress towards that
destination or not and that's that's how
this stuff works